انطلقت اليوم السبت للانتخابات النيابيه
والمجالس البلديه في البحرين وتسجلها هذه
الانتخابات رقما قياسيا في اعداد المرشحين
بلغ
57 في حين يبلغه مجموع من يحق لهم التصويت
في الانتخابات
344,713 ناخبا بحسبه وكاله الانباء
البحرينيه وزاره الداخليه البحرينيه كشفت
عن استهداف مواقع الكترونيه في البلاد
بهدف تعطيل العمليات الانتخابيه وبث رسائل
سلبيه للتاثير عليها وذكر بيان الوزراء
عبر حسابها في تويتر ان عمليات
الاستهدافيه محاولات يائسه ولن تنال من
عزيمه المواطنين الذين سيتوجهون السبت الى
مراكز التصويت وفقا للبيع
وقد وصف وزير الداخليه البحريني الشيخ
راشد ال خليفه الهجمات التي استهدفت مواقع
الكترونيه حكوميه قبيلا انطلاق الانتخابات
التشريعيه وصفها بالمحاولات اليائسه مؤكدا
في الوقت ذاته ان الاجهزه الامنيه تعاملت
معها باحترافيه تامه
ولله الحمد تم التعامل معها فورا
واللي يشوف اليوم من تواجد وحضور وهو خير
جواب على هذه المحاولات الياس ولكن يعني
في ظلها الحضور اسمحوا لي اني انا يعني
انا ابارك سيدي حدد صاحب الجلاله هذا
النجاح وهذا الحضور والمشاركه الوطنيه
اللافته اللي تعودناها من المواطنين
وشكرا لحضوركم معنا وان شاء الله نتمنى
التوفيق للجميع ان شاء الله
البحرين وزير العدل والشؤون الاسلاميه
والاوقاف رئيس اللجنه المشرفه على
الانتخابات بن محمد المعاوده
سيدنا وفاء اهلا وسهلا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه همم يعني اولا نريد ان نتعرف اكثر
على هذه العمليه الاستهداف طبيعتها حجمها
والجهه التي تقف وراءها اذا كان اذا كنت
وصلتم في تحقيقكم الى الى هذه الجهه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم واشكر لكم هذه
الاستضافه الله يحييك في البدايه احبنا
وبين الله الحمد
في هذا اليوم
الساعه 8:00 صباحا فتحت جميع مراكز
الاقتراح في مملكه البحرين
وقبل فتح الابواب كانت هناك عديده وحسود
من الناخبين الحريصين على مشاركتهم في هذا
اليوم
والاستحقاق والدستوري همم ولله الحمد سير
العمليه الانتخابيه الى هذه اللحظه وجود
كثافه كثيره في جميع مراكز الاقتراع
الفرعيه والعامه
ونتمنى همم ان تستمر هذه الكثافه الى حين
اغلاق المراكز في الساعه 8:00 مساء همم
طبعا لا الحمد يعني همم
الاستهداف اللي حاول همم
لبعض المواقع في مملكه البحرين كانت
محدوده جدا والاهل لم تؤثر في اي همم شيء
من همم اا من مرحله مراحل انتخاب
والمواطن البحريني واعي لحقه الدستوري وان
هذه الاستهدافات همم لم تؤثر في اي همم من
مراحل
الانتخابات والاستهدف جديد يعني لاول مره
ام انه متكرر مع الوزير
هو يحاول يستهدفون في اكثر من جهه معينه
ولكن هي فقط لمواقع الكترونيه
وكان استهداف ضعيف جدا ولله الحمد همم لم
يؤثر في اي من مراحل هذه الانتخابات
والبحرينيين وعين يحققهم وحريصين على
مشاركتهم في هذه الانتخابات واكبر دليل
التغطيه التي حصلت همم من قناه كوم وهمم
قناه البحرين التي اثبتت الطوابير الى
خارج المدارز ومشاركه من جميع فئات
المجتمع شاركوا في هذا العرس الانتخابي
الذي
صاحب الجلاله ملك البلاد المعظم وبدعم من
سيدي صاحب السمو ولي العهد رئيس مجلس
الوزراء حفظه الله همم نبين والمؤشرات
تبين همم ان هناك نجاح خادم باذن الله في
اعلان النتائج همم عرفتوا مين هي الجهه
التي تقف وراء هذا الاستئناف او الدوله
همم هناك اجهزه متخصصه قائمه بالتحقيق في
هذا الموضوع وسوف تعلم بعد انتهاء نتائج
التحقيق في ذلك من هو وزاره الداخليه
واجهزه الامس براني في كتب البحريني وكلها
تتعاون في حصر هذه الهجمات وكانت هي جدا
حدد هجمات
الحمد لله لم تاثر في اي شيء من العمليه
للانتخابات مع هذه العمليه ربما كان هناك
بعض الدعوات من البعض ايضا لمقاطعه
الانتخابات ال همم كانوا لها اي تاثير هذه
الدعوه
ارجع ناكد وعي المواطن البحريني في حقه
الدستوري ومشاركته الديمقراطيه في
البرلمان واختياره المرشح بكل سريه
وديمقراطيه
وانعكاس ذلك على الحشود التي كانت مصطفى
من قبل فتح باب المراكز القراءه والى الان
هذا يبين مدى وعي المواطن وعدم الالتفات
حق اي اي دعوات يعني تحاول ان تضر او تمس
في هذه المسيره الان كيف تسير عمليه
الاقتراع همم متى ستنتهي الفتره الزمنيه
يعني مش الخطوه الثانيه
لله الحمد مرحله
المراكز الاقتراع مرحله الاختيارات
للمرشحين ما زالت مستمره من الساعه 8:00
صباحا الى الان في 55 مركز منها 40 مركز
فرعي
وخمسه عشر مركز عام احدى المراكز خصصتها
مملكه البحرين لاعطاء الفرصه لمصابين
بالمرض كورونا
المشاركه وقد حرصت في توفير هذا المركز
همم بالتعاون مع وزاره الصحه
الاحترازات اللازمه همم بصوت همم حرصنا ان
تقدم الخدمه لجميع فئه المجتمع ولا تحرم
حتى فئات المصابين بالكوفد من يستطيع
الانتقال الى هذا المركز ف- بصوته وان شاء
الله الساعه 8:00 مساء تغلق مراكز
الاقتراع وسوف تعد همم اوراق يتم عده
اوراق الاقتراع في مراكز الاقتراع
ويتم اعلام همم المرشحين والمراقبين
الموجودين داخل المراكز بكل بالنتائج وبعد
ذلك سوف تعلن النتيجه من اللجنه الاشرافيه
ومن بعدها اللجنه العليا همم وكل ذلك سوف
يكون خلال اليوم باذن الله اشكرك شكر جزيل